did you know that two out of every three
guys are gonna experience some form of
male pattern borders by the time they're
35 look I know it for me it was more
like 25. I wish keeps have been around
when I was younger because advancements
in science meant that there are now
treatments that can combat the symptoms
of hair loss and help you keep the hair
that you have it's too late for me my
hair is not coming back he doesn't have
to be like me you could stop your hair
loss early thanks to keeps keep Stoppers
generic versions of the only two FDA
approved drugs for treating hair loss so
you might have tried them before but
never had a price this low that's right
if you were thinking some sort of
medicine sounds gonna be expensive well
that couldn't be further from the truth
as keep starts at just ten dollars a
month how does it work well for one
thing no need to visit the doctor's
office you just schedule a quick online
consult a little bit later a discrete
package is going to arrive at your door
and you can use it in the privacy of
your own home so look if you're noticing
that you're losing your hat that's one
problem that's not going to fit itself
do something about it for a limited time
go to keeps.com biographics or click the
link in the description below and you'll
get 50 off your first order and now
today's video
foreign
ER and Alvin coppers think you're too
ruthless and Reckless you know you might
have a screw or too loot George Nelson
Always the perfect embodiment of the
praise looks can be deceiving his small
stature and boyish features suggested a
respectable even innocent young man
hence his nickname Babyface that however
could not have been further from the
truth behind that youthful appearance in
a cold and calculated killer one who
knew of only one way of dealing with
problems violence one true crime writer
pointed out the key difference between
Nelson and his Confederates from the
public enemy era while many had no
qualms about killing most of the others
did it in order to protect themselves or
to escape Babyface Nelson on the other
hand went out of his way to murder
because he liked it he was a psychopath
who had found the perfect career
Babyface Nelson was born Lester Joseph
Gillis on December 6 1908 in the near
West Side neighborhood of Chicago the
youngest of seven children to Joseph
Gillis and Marie dugay his parents were
both Belgian immigrants who grew up
together in the same city of leuven they
left for America separately and found
each other again in Chicago and decided
to get hitched a few months later Joseph
Gillis was an industrious-skilled Tanner
who made enough money to build his
family a three-story RedBrick House near
Humboldt Park meanwhile Marie was a
former school teacher who hoped to
further her education in America maybe
even resume teaching but had to give up
those Ambitions in order to look after
their ever-growing family both parents
worked hard to provide their children
with a good upbringing and instill in
them other traits of Integrity honesty
and diligence in most cases it worked
but not a little Leicester who began
straying from the straight and narrow
path from an early age in his pre-teen
years when puberty swept through the
neighborhood all the other boys shot up
like weeds but Leicester reached five
foot four and his body said well that's
nothing you his small size plus his
eponymous Babyface made him an easy
target for bullies so Lester was picked
on regularly until he decided to fight
back at 12 years old he already had a
Napoleon complex and overcompensated for
his short stature with ruthless
aggression it doesn't matter how old or
big the other kid was Lester never
backed down for a confrontation and he
didn't shy away from fighting dirty
either as long as the other kid was down
and Z was standing that's all that
mattered in a short while Lester Gillis
developed a reputation as the toughest
kid in the neighborhood and he began
hanging out with like-minded individuals
or in other words a gang of juvenile
delinquents called the Halsted Street
boys school became almost a non-factor
in leicester's life he was expelled
several times for truancy and the story
repeated itself each time was enrolled
at a new school his parents knew that
they had a troubled child on their hands
but they kept convincing themselves that
his actions were the result of an
over-energetic personality or simply
Boyhood pranks this changed in 1922 when
13 year old Leicester was arrested for
car theft and sent to 18 months inside
the Illinois state school for boys in
Saint Charles at first he hated it there
which was hardly surprising but things
started getting better once Leicester
transferred to work in the machine shop
he discovered that Not only was he good
at it but he enjoyed working with
Machinery to the point where he began
volunteering to do extra jobs in order
to help out other students he also
performed well during military drills
and while his schoolwork wasn't exactly
on a raw material he did enough to get
by by the time Lester was due to leave
he actually agreed to stay an extra
month so that he could graduate the
eighth grade and get his diploma once he
got back home his mother desperately
hoped that Lester's time inside the
Reformatory School genuinely had changed
him whether he wanted to find a job or
continuous studies she was okay with
either one as long as he stayed out of
trouble but alas we know that neither of
those came to be soon after returning
home Leicester started hanging out with
some of his old friends again one summer
day they got caught taking a joyride in
a stolen car and Leicester was sent back
to Reformatory school during his second
stint in juvie a combination of
alcoholism depression and financial woes
drove Joseph Gillis to sue side racked
with guilt over his father's death
Leicester tried to go straight again and
when he was released he even found a job
as an assistant mechanic but it was the
same old story The Ice life simply
didn't stick to Lester and the promise
of easy money steered him towards a life
of crime again this time with no looking
back
[Music]
despite Lester's attractions motoring
malfeasance he was certainly no criminal
mastermind almost exactly one year after
being released from Saint Charles Gillis
always arrested while stealing another
car and was sent to the Reformatory
school for the third and the final time
he was over 18 when he got out so from
then on if he got popped he risked jail
time this didn't deter Leicester however
he kept hanging out in the same Shady
places with the same Shady people so
it's only a matter of time before he
turned shady as well Leicester started
out small by joining a tire theft ring
with a few neighborhood buddies but he
got pinched almost immediately during a
burglary he only got probation thanks to
some heavy pleading from his mother as
before the arrest was followed by a
brief law-abiding period but this one
was notable because Gillis met and
married a teenage sales girl named Helen
wasiniak once the honeymoon period was
over Gillis got back to work with a spot
of bootlegging since that was the big
money maker of the time some reports
claimed Lester ran with an Irish mob
called the Tui gang for a while although
this this relationship was short-lived
and frivolous this was probably better
for Gillis since the Tui gang soon ran a
foul of Al Capone who was in the midst
of his Ascent to the top of the criminal
world and wanted to exert a Stranglehold
on Chicago's bootlegging industry
speaking of Capone his association with
Gillis is probably the most uncertain
aspect of the latter's life to the point
where we're not even sure if there was
one some sources claim that there was a
small window where Gillis worked for
Capone under his Capo Jack mcgurn the
job mainly involved getting labor unions
to fall in line but Lester got kicked
out because he was too gung-ho when it
came to dishing out corporal punishment
some even say that Gillis killed his
first man during this period but as we
mentioned we can't guarantee any of this
ever happened two things we can tape are
certain though one this was around the
time that Gillis Advanced from
bootlegging and car theft more violent
crimes and two at least it wasn't
Leicester anymore he started going by
George Nelson we can't really say why
maybe he simply thought it sounded
cooler what we can say despite the name
change is that he still got stuck with
the nickname he absolutely hated and the
one by which she is remembered even
today Babyface Nelson
even if Nelson was involved with the mob
it was short-lived he preferred to
operate with a small group of
like-minded Outlaws who all shared the
same goal making money that being said
there was nothing to gain from making
enemies of the mob so Nelson stayed away
from bootlegging and other rackets that
Capone might have an interest in instead
he decided to become a jewelry Thief
with the onset of the Great Depression
Banks were closing and businesses were
failing left and right Nelson concluded
that rich people would store their money
in things that wouldn't lose their value
such as Jewels therefore any big fancy
houses in the Swanky parts of Chicago
were likely to have a lot of bling ripe
for the taking baby first Nelson put his
idea to the test on January 6 1930. his
Target was 1418 Lakeshore Drive The
Mansion of consolidation magazine
Corporation vice president Charles
Richter that night Nelson and four
cohorts forced their way into the
Richter household armed with pistols and
shotguns and quickly gained control of
the mansion's occupants the Richter's
cooperated gave up their valuables and
the robbers were out of the door in 20
minutes carrying about 25 000 in plunder
Nelson almost couldn't believe how easy
it was was While others struggled to put
food on the table just a few minutes of
work made him more money than the
average American made in a year from
that point on never again would he
attempt to go straight the life of the
working stiff was for suckers just a
couple of weeks later the gang pulled
off another Heist this time they
targeted the house of a wealthy attorney
just the maids were home which made the
job even easier they got only five
thousand dollars worth of valuables but
it was still a decent haul for one
night's work both ice pailed in
comparison to Nelson's third robbery in
March 1930 when he raided the van bulo
Mansion of seventy thousand dollars
worth of jewelry and cash and there were
only three robbers this time so each
share was bigger three quick robberies
in and out netting a hundred thousand
dollars was about 1.6 million dollars in
today's money but that was what the loot
was worth it wasn't anywhere near what
the thieves could get for it by the time
of the third Heist Chicago was up in
arms about this new Criminal ring which
was targeting the city's rich and
Powerful the stolen Jewels were as hot
as Hades on a summer Sunday so most
fences either didn't want to touch them
or only offered Pennies on the dollar
therefore Babyface Nelson unsung
ceremoniously brought an end to his
career as a jewel thief and decided to
deal strictly with paper currency from
then on his first transaction came on
October 3rd 1930 when he and his two
Pals robbed the State Bank of a tasker
in DuPage County making off with over 4
600 in Cold Hard Cash next up was the
bank in Plainfield Illinois but the
criminals had to leave empty-handed as
the bank manager smiled at them smugly
behind bulletproof glass their third
stick up however at the hillside State
Bank went much smoother and resulted in
about the same amount of money as their
first bank heist soon enough the police
realized that these robberies were all
being committed by the same gang after
all the criminals didn't really make an
effort to hide their identities and
there was one person that stood out to
all the witnesses a short guy with
blonde hair and deep blue eyes and the
cherubic look of an innocent youngster
and anonymous tip from the Chicago
underworld even got the police a name
George Nelson doctor called Babyface and
big George behind his back rounding up
the suspects wasn't exactly the work of
Kojak as we said the crew didn't come
cover their tracks very well by February
1931 Nelson and his two main accomplices
were in custody all taken in without a
fight they had been identified by a few
dozen Witnesses so the case against them
was as solid as granite and the police
chief was cheerfully touting the arrest
of the stick up Trio as among the most
important in the police history of
Chicago one of the subordinates even
included the Babyface name in the
official press release for the media
thus ensuring that Nelson would forever
be immortalized by the moniker that he
hated most the trial went about as well
as you'd expect one of the Three Robbers
testified against the other two in
exchange for probation the other pled
guilty for a reduced sentence only
Nelson refused to deal he insisted that
he was innocent but the jury wasn't
taken in by his boyish charm they took
less than two hours to find him guilty
Nelson was then sentenced to one year to
life in the state prison a Joliet
foreign
spent less than one year in prison in
February 1932 it was due to stand trial
for a solo robbery but for some reason
the authorities concluded that a single
Burly prison guard would be enough to
keep an eye on the diminutive delinquent
the duo was riding the train back to
Joliet when Nelson managed to get his
hands on a 45 automatic most likely
hidden by an accomplice Babyface took
the guard and a taxi driver hostage and
drove to the middle of nowhere that's
when he told them to get out and he rode
off alone into the sunset with the law
in his tail Nelson fled Illinois and
made his way to Reno Nevada he didn't
spend a lot of time there but enough for
him to Pal around with some other
prominent Outlaws of that era such as
Alvin karpis who ran the Barker gang and
Eddie benster Confederate of Machine Gun
Kelly they pulled off several heists
together this time traveling from state
to state instead of staying in the same
place and making it as far north as
Minnesota however it was in Sausalito
California that Nelson made the
acquaintance of John Paul chase the man
who would become his new partner in
crime until The Bitter End after
bullying a few scores with more various
bank robbers like carpers and bents
Nelson gained the confidence to start
his own crew Chase was his right-hand
man and other members included Eddie
Green Tommy Carroll and Homer Van Meter
together they executed a string of
robberies all across the country most
notorious was other one in Brainerd
Minnesota feeling cocky following a
textbook bank heist the gang wanted to
leave guns blazing literally Nelson and
Van Meter stuck their tommy guns out the
windows of their getaway car as they
sped out of town and sprayed both sides
of the street bullets they smashed
dozens of stores and car windows but
through some miracle they didn't hit a
single person not that fatalities would
have bothered them too much the gang
soon claimed their first known victim in
a gunfight with San Antonio police were
detective Henry perro was shot and
killed as to the trigger man Witnesses
claimed Tommy Carroll was the killer but
he was never positively id'd that is
pretty much how Nelson and his gang
spent 1933. although George's wife never
participated in any of the robberies she
accepted that this was who he was and
often followed him around with the kids
so the family could spend time together
when Evan Nelson was laying low it was
during this time that Nelson met with
another Leading Light of the underworld
someone the Van Meter did dine with back
in Indiana John Dillinger the two gangs
met up at a safe house in Chicago their
little gathering was cordial enough they
swapped Adventures they exchanged useful
contacts and they drank all except
Nelson he never touched alcohol after
what he did to his father and that
always about it
at least for the time being
now that if you've seen our biographics
video on John Dillinger you would know
that the Dillinger gang had two distinct
incarnations in January 1934 the first
crew was captured in Tucson Arizona and
all the original members found
themselves in prison except for one guy
named red Hamilton like Dillinger
Hamilton was on good terms with Van
Meter and with nowhere else to turn to
he joined up with Nelson's gang after
all as far as he knew none of his former
compatriots would see life outside the
Prison Walls ever again with some of
them even scoring a date with the
electric chair but John Dillinger
escaped prison in early March perhaps
even with Hamilton's help and was
itching to stick up a few Banks the old
gang was gone but Hamilton had already
hooked up with a new crew the only
question was could dylinder and Nelson
get along here are two guys who both
wanted to be the leader are one of them
with a serious overcompensation problem
they had what you would call A Clash of
personalities and Nelson was none to
please whenever other gang members would
turn to Dillinger instead of him since
he liked to think that he was the one in
charge he probably blew a gasket when he
saw the newspapers referring to the
group as the Dillinger gang and he
reacted rather predictably with violence
it was at this time that baby first
Nelson fully embraced his dark side and
turned into the most ruthless man in the
country even before pulling off their
first Heist Nelson killed a paint
salesman from Minnesota named Ted killer
he gunned him down in front of a diner
while his wife her mother-in-law watched
why exactly he did this nobody is sure
to this day then when the gang did
commit their first robbery together the
Security National Bank in Sioux Falls
South Dakota Nelson let loose with his
tommy gun on a motorcycle patrolman
named hail Keith and as the officer
collapsed the ground he proudly shouted
I got one I got one with all the bodies
they kept dropping came increased heat
from the police not to mention that the
FBI got involved as well shootouts
between the two sides became more
frequent and more vile and ultimately
making it clear that it was only one way
this would end
foreign
was the first to go following a shootout
with the FBI at his hideout in Saint
Paul Minnesota in early April a couple
of weeks later the rest of the gang and
their wives and girlfriends were laying
low at the Little Bohemia Lodge in
Wisconsin someone tipped off the feds
about their presence which led to a
botch raid that turned into a bloodbath
the Lawman opened fire on a group of
innocent bystanders in a case of
mistaken identity killing a man named
Eugene boisner the gunshots tipped off
Dillinger and the Gang who returned fire
and managed to make it to their cars and
Escape leaving the women behind
meanwhile Nelson was the only one who
wasn't with the group when the shooting
started so he felt he had to make it on
his own he ran through the woods for a
while before stealing a vehicle and then
driving to a remote house where he took
everyone hostage unbeknownst to him
however the people inside called the
authorities as soon as they saw the
vehicle pull up in front of their home a
police car arrived on the scene with two
FBI agents in the local constable and
Nelson gleefully opened fire on them all
two of them were seriously wounded while
special agent W Carter bomb was hit in
the neck and died in minutes Nelson then
got into the car and drove away after
the shootout at Little Bohemia the gang
went their separate ways maybe they
planned on reuniting later who knows but
they never got the chance because they
started dropping like flies Hamilton
died in another gunfight just a few days
later then over the summer Tommy Carroll
Homer band meter and even Dillinger
himself all bit the big one following
shootouts with law enforcement all of a
sudden it was just Nelson his wife Helen
Gillis and John Paul Chase finally both
Face Nelson got to enjoy the notoriety
of being Public Enemy Number One for a
short while at least Nelson wisely
decided to keep a low profile and stay
on the move but that is easier said than
done when you're the most Wanted Man in
the country he had a close call in late
November in Lake Geneva Wisconsin when
he ran into some feds staking out a
former Hideout of his but he managed to
get away uncharacteristically without
firing a single shot but even so the
Noose was tightening around Nelson's
neck the FBI now at his car his number
plates and were hot on his tail they
caught up to him on November 27 1934 in
the town of Barrington Illinois and
staged one final shoot out that wouldn't
fill out a place in any action movie
with three cars one filled with
criminals two with FBI agents racing on
the highway side by side Nelson drove
while Chase took out one car with a few
well-placed shots but their own vehicle
took a bullet to the radiator that left
them partially disabled minutes later
their ride conked out so Nelson veered
off the highway into a park in
Barrington the second FBI car with agent
Samuel Cowley and Hermann Hollis pulled
up close to it but it was immediately
met with a spray of bullets from Nelson
to chase the Lawman a returned fire but
the crooks had the upper hands Hollis
was shot and killed during the battle
while Cowley was mortally injured Belton
and his accomplices got into the FBI car
and drove away seemingly Triumph them
once again but that was not the case
this time Chase and Helen Gillis might
have escaped unscathed but the same
could not be said for Nelson who had
sustained several gunshot wounds just a
few hours later Babyface Nelson was dead
his body was found the next day in a
cemetery in a nearby town both Helen
Gillis and John Paul Chase were arrested
soon after she served one year in prison
for harboring a known know while Chase
spent 32 years behind bars before being
released on parole in 1966. as for baby
pearls Nelson he liked to brag that he
would never be taken alive and he got
his wish a bloody but unsurprising end
Juan of the most ruthless criminals in
American history